the trial of Jonathan major has begun
Jonathan major of course plays Kang the
Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe he was introduced in Loki
season 1 as a king variant he who
remains and then we got introduced to
the full King an Ant-Man and the WASP
quantam Mania Jonathan major was
arrested in Manhattan on March 25th
after an alleged domestic dispute with
his then girlfriend at the time Grace
Jabari he was charged with assault an
aggravated harassment and a charge of
strangulation has been dropped however
if he is found guilty and convicted he
still faces up to a year in jail the
trial recently began and we're going to
go over everything that has happened so
far including the testimony of the
alleged victim Grace Jabari and the
testimony of four other people one of
which was the driver of the car in which
majors and Jabari got in the fight in
we'll go over everything in great detail
in this video before opening statements
begin a jury was selected on November
29th and November 30th it consists of
six jurors comprised of Three Men and
three women as well as two Alternatives
then on Monday December 4th the opening
statements began prosecutor Michael
Perez began by offering details on the
events that led to Major's arrest on
March 25th majors and Jabari took a
private car service after midnight from
a Brooklyn party to their Chelsea
apartment the prosecutor said the couple
who met in 2021 on the set of Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania had been
together for 2 years and had disced
marriage and kids this was a serious
relationship Perez told jurors on the
night of the incident Jabari saw a text
message on major's phone from a woman
named Cleopatra that read wish I was
kissing you right now Jabari allegedly
took the phone out of his hands to see
who sent the message Perez asserted that
Majors then began grabbing the right
side of jabari's body and prying her
finger off the phone to retrieve it the
prosecutor said this caused bruising
swelling and substantial pain he
intended to cause Grace Jabari physical
injury and in fact he did cause her
physical injury Perez asserted what's
interesting is that majors does not deny
that a text message from another woman
sparked the alleged altercation however
Majors aside his criminal defense lawyer
priia chadri alleges that it was Jabari
who assaulted Majors which is what they
have been claiming this entire time that
Jonathan Majors is actually the victim
in this altercation and this entire case
and they state that Majors was assaulted
and priia chadri ripped two buttons off
of his coat and tore his pocket with her
bare hands and not the other way around
she assaulted him he did not assault her
this was a statement made by Major's
team after the altercation in the car
took place both of them left and parted
ways after they parted ways Jabari ran
into three strangers on the street who
invited her to go to a club she went to
supposedly block out the experience
that's what Perez told the jurors
meanwhile Jonathan major checked into a
hotel room and ended their relationship
through a text message after the
nightclub Jabari would return to Major's
apartment and called him multiple times
32 times according to priia chadri she
then took two sleeping pills went to
sleep and when Jonathan major got back
to the apartment he found Jabari on the
floor of his closet when Jonathan major
found her he was the one who actually
called the police and according to
charie he called the police out of
concern for jabari's mental state
because she was unconscious and in her
text messages to him she had threatened
suicide when Jabari woke up they say
that she was hesitant but eventually
told officers that she had sustained
injuries from Majors who was then
subsequently arrested but what's
important to know about this particular
court date was that they did mention
that Jabari herself the alleged victim
was arrested on October 26th and charged
with assault and criminal mischief in
connection to the March incident but the
Manhattan District Attorney's Office
declined to prosecute the case against
Grace Jabari because it lacked
prosecutorial Merit however the judge
Michael gaffy ruled on thir Thursday the
defense can bring up jabari's arrest
during the trial this court session
ended with jabari's lawyer Perez stating
that before this incident occurred the
honeymoon period of majors and jabari's
partnership was waning and things had
began to sour he states that months into
the relationship that defendant's true
self began to show and he began to snap
at manipulate and strategically withhold
affection from Jabari and that he had
threatened suicide to her to control her
actions in the past then Major's team
testified and they argued that this was
about the end of a relationship not
about a crime and it had nothing to do
with what happened in the car the
defense argued that Major's Hollywood
career had been on the rise before the
arrest he was an Emmy nominee and was in
the indie film magazine dreams and of
course was in Creed 3 and Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania chadri stated and
I quote Mr Major's lifetime of hard work
was coming to fruition and his career
seemed Unstoppable until he ended his
relationship with Jabari and she made
these false allegations this is a man
who spent 30 years working hard to get
where he was on March 25th a man with
the world at his fingertips end quote
and she concluded the opening statement
by stating this is a case about the end
of a relationship not about a crime at
least not one that Mr major committed in
Revenge she made these false allegations
to ruin Mr major and take away
everything he spent his life working for
and she urged the jury and I quote end
this nightmare for him end quote then on
Tuesday December 5th the alleged victim
Grace Jabari testified she testified
that during their two years together
Majors could become volatile and
controlling and he would threaten
suicide after fights and she said that
during the altercation in March Majors
struck her head they also played an
audio recording during the trial in
which they heard Jonathan major say I'm
a great man a great man I do great
things for my culture and for my world
the woman that supports me needs to be a
great woman according to Jabari Majors
demanded that she should behave like
Michelle Obama or ketta Scott King the
wives of Barack Obama and Martin Luther
King Jr then the jury was shown a
surveillance video of Majors getting out
of the car and Jabari following him the
video seemingly showned Majors pushing
her back into the car Jabari testified
that she went with the three strangers
that she met on the street to the bar
because she didn't want to be alone she
stated that on the night of the incident
the physical pain wasn't registering she
wasn't aware that there was pain in her
body she said I hadn't registered
anything I'm a dancer I've danced with a
broken rib I was only thinking from my
heart of the infidelity that morning we
were talking about when we were going to
get married and the names of our
children she would continue to go on to
state that he was really kind and loving
in the beginning he told me he loved me
very early on which was overwhelming but
I loved it and I loved him he wrote me
poetry I felt very loved and cared for
and seen then she said in December 2021
she was going to meet Major's dogs and
she alleged that that Majors berated her
for bringing up a former boyfriend's pet
and she stated and I quote it was the
first time I felt scared of him I knew
to never mention my ex again or anyone I
had dated before she then relayed
another incident in June of 2022 she
attended the Glastonberry Festival in
England with her friends and she told
Jonathan major that she wouldn't likely
have cell service given the crowds and
when she didn't she said that major got
upset with her and sent her a ton of
messages saying that she shouldn't be
there and how dare she go she said the
exchange made her feel guilty so she
ended up leaving the festival but when
she tried to get in touch with Jonathan
major and tried to see him he wasn't
talking to her and he didn't respond to
her messages or calls she then said that
immediately after though it was quite
nice again and he was apologetic and
thanked her for her patience with him
she said that she told Majors that she'd
never tell anybody about that side of
the relationship she said I felt like I
had to keep a lot of Secrets from
everyone I felt very isolated it was
confusing I felt scared of him but quite
dependent on him and she said that the
relation relationship continued because
she loved him Jabari said that after
fights majes would refer to himself as a
monster and make threats of suicide and
that she would plead with him that he
couldn't do that think about your
daughter think about your mother and she
would try to make him feel safe and
secure and he would receive that but
Jabari said that this took a toll in
their relationship and made her feel
isolated that she was just existing in
his world and she had low self-esteem
and lost a lot of weight they then
returned to the courtroom the next day
Wednesday December 6th where she
testified again in where she said that
she didn't want to call the police on
him because of a previous conversation
that they had where he warned her about
trusting the police because of what they
would do to him as a black man and keep
in mind that it was actually Jonathan
major who called the police not Jabari
she said she woke up to loads of
officers and was hesitant but eventually
told the officers that she had sustained
injuries from majors and to add a little
bit of context to this what priia chadri
Jonathan Major's lawyer has said is that
there is evidence from the body cam of
the police officer officers of the
police officers actually telling her to
say that she was assaulted by him this
hasn't seemingly been brought up in
court yet but it is something that priia
chadri has claimed in the past Jabari
said that she felt like it was her fault
and that she should have lied and said
nothing happened so Jonathan major
wouldn't be in trouble or upset with her
and that she wanted to fix it she then
testified that she asked for the charges
to be dropped against Majors because she
and I quote didn't understand the
context around end quote she then
testified about the pain that she felt
after the alleged assault she said I
couldn't lie on the right side of my
body everywhere hurt I'm used to muscle
aches pain inflicted in other ways as a
dancer this felt so uncomfortable the
jury was shown photos of jabari's
swollen finger and a cut behind her ear
that she took the day after the alleged
assault then the defense argues that
Jabari fabricated these allegations to
get back at Majors after their breakup
with chadri stating again this is the
case about the end of a relationship not
about a crime at least not one that
Majors committed and that it was was
actually Jabari who assaulted Majors the
audio was also brought up again where
Majors called himself a great man and
chodri sought to give the jury some
context to help explain why Majors was
scolding Jabari on the recording and she
asked Jabari if her drinking habits had
been a constant source of tension in the
relationship but Jabari said he would
get upset with me and use my drinking as
an excuse the trial then continued on
Thursday December 7th where Jonathan
maor's attorney priia chadri got to
cross-examine Grace Jabari asking her a
bunch of questions when it came down to
her alleged injuries after the alleged
assault she had asked why she had gone
out to a nightclub immediately after the
alleged assault took place suggesting
that her injuries must not have been
particularly serious in which Jabari
said I was feeling pain but I was
choosing to ignore it I was filled with
adrenaline the next morning is when the
pain suck in when I woke up I felt like
I had been hit by a bus the jury was
shown footage of Jabari at the nightclub
in which chadri asked if Jabari hit her
head on the DJ booth in which she
responded I did not the video also
showed Jabari touching her hair as she
left the club in which chadri asked if
Jabari felt blood on her head in which
she replied I didn't touch behind my ear
so I didn't they also showed
surveillance footage of the street of
Jonathan majors and Grace Jabari on the
side of the street chadri questioned
Jabari about playing with and fluffing
her hair despite the laceration behind
her right ear and pain in her finger in
which Jabari responded with I wasn't
thinking about pain at this point I was
upset the next day on December 8th Grace
Jabari ended her testimony and then we
heard from one of her friends and a
police officer who was on the scene when
majers was arrested Grace jabari's
friend and colleague Holly Blakeley was
called as a witness and she said that
when she first met Jonathan majers he
was very sweet and charming and very
loving but she then noticed a change in
Jabari as the coupled continued their
relationship she said that Jabari would
be in the house a lot more and seemed to
have a lot less interest in herself she
was working a lot less she used used to
have a lot of energy and was very
self-driven but she saw a lot of that
disappear she also testified that Grace
Jabari called her the morning after the
alleged assault took place and she sent
her photos of the injury in which
Blakeley said I'd never heard her like
that before quite quiet wrecked in shock
like she'd been crying in a way it was
an entirely different emotional
landscape it was different she was very
very broken a very traumatized person
then the NYPD officer who responded to
the 911 call and arrested Majors Brendan
Swain testified they also reviewed his
personal body cam footage on the witness
stand Swain testified that he had
noticed jabari's middle finger was
bruised and that she had a cut behind
her right ear that was an inch and a
half long Swain then took Majors into
another room to ask Jabari privately
what had happened to cause her injuries
he then said that Grace Jabari whispered
saying that she didn't want him right
outside the room and he said that she
seemed scared and started to cry the
trial then concluded yesterday December
11th Monday morning where more witnesses
took the stand including two of the
three strangers that Jabari met on the
street and went to the nightclub with
and the driver of the private car they
were in two of the three people that
Jabari met on the street Khloe Zer and
Max Manning testified that Jabari was
visibly upset but didn't notice any
injuries on her when they met her Zer
then said that Jabari complained about
her finger hurting at the club so he
gave her some ice from a drink bucket on
their table to apply to it but here's
where things get pretty interesting when
Navid sair the driver of the car
testified he said he'd been hired as
Major's private driver for the day and
have driven him and Jabari to the
Brooklyn Academy of Music and then to a
restaurant for dinner he said the couple
seemed good earlier in the day until
Jabari noticed the text message on
major's phone in the evening soar
testified that Jabari became angry and
she and major started arguing he said I
was feeling something going on in the
back seat when I reached canal and
Center Street Majors wanted to get rid
of Jabari and he opened the door I saw
they were fighting when the car stopped
he was trying to get rid of her then the
prosecution played video footage from
security and traffic cameras that showed
major and jabari's altercation them
leaving sar's car and then Jabari
meeting the three people on the street
then Saar said I do remember Majors was
pushing her back into the car trying to
get rid of her he said Jabari was
yelling at Majors and they were having
an argument I had a feeling Jabari had
hit Majors earlier the way she was
fighting and the sounds produced and he
added he was not doing anything she was
doing it he was trying to get rid of her
he was saying leave me alone I have to
go so from the driver's point of view
from what he heard and the way Jabari
was acting he feels like it was Jabari
who was hitting Jonathan majors and not
the other way around and that Jonathan
major was trying to get rid of her
trying to get away and this is
everything that has happened so far in
the trial of Jonathan Majors right now
the way this is going to go is very
unclear we've heard a lot of testimonies
one from Grace Jabari herself then
others that the prosecution has called
but we haven't really heard anything
from Major's team yet no witnesses that
they've really called except for the
driver and Jonathan major himself hasn't
testified yet if he is even going to do
so but a lot left Still Remains in this
trial so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell so you don't miss
any of the latest news about it also if
you subscribe and leave a comment down
below you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick a winner at the end of
each month you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof